(energetic tonal music)
- I'm at the Nangang Exhibition
center in Taipei City
where FOXCONN is having it's
2021 tech day.
FOXCONN is best known for
assembling iPhones for Apple,
and it announced three
of it's own EV models.
Including a SUV, a sedan,
and an electric bus.
- (speaks in foreign language)
(energetic tonal music)
(crowd applauds)
(classical string music)
- FOXCONN is the world's largest
contract electronics manufacturer,
and has been moving
further and further into
the automotive industry in an attempt
to diversify it's business.
Over the past year, it
has announced a series of
deals and partnerships.
Most recently, it has
said that it will buy
an Ohio factory from electric truck maker
LORDSTOWN Motors.
As a part of that, LORDSTOWN
said that it would also use
FOXCONN to manufacture it's vehicles,
including it's debut
electric pick-up truck.
(energetic tonal music)
Given FOXCONN's supply chain experience
and existing relationship with Apple,
that could put it in a
particularly good position
for manufacturing any
potential future Apple cars.
As far as Apple car comments or news goes,
the company has not said
anything on that front.
(energetic tonal music)